hey Vsauce I've got a quick and fun
video for you today because I made a
mistake last week on episode 10 of IMG I
showed a picture and I said cats and
dogs cooperating however if you look at
the picture for more than a second you
can tell that it's not a cat it's a
monkey when a commenter pointed that out
to me my mind was blown and so now I'm
gonna return the favor
prepare to get blown in the mine first
stop Super Mario Galaxy many of you may
have already discovered this but if you
read each letter and only each letter
that has a star underneath it on the
cover of the game it spells out you are
mr. gay Mario but don't worry we might
get the last laugh
here it is an online flash game you can
play right now called duck hunt
more specifically kill the dog from duck
hunt that's right after all of these
years you finally have the power
unfortunately Nintendo may have
one-upped us remember this after
completing the castle it turns out toad
has been flipping us off the entire time
the Chicago Bulls logo upside down is a
robot reading a book and if you actually
look closely the doom guy has only ever
had one gun more importantly the poster
for Silence of the land's we've all seen
it but have you ever noticed all of the
naked women I'm serious let's get a
little closer in on the skull good do
you see it it's a portrait by Salvador
Dali and hey what the H let's do an
audio illusion you're going to need
headphones for this but if you don't
have them I'll do a visual illusion
simultaneously okay
stare into the middle of these swirling
shapes and listen through your
headphones you'll hear someone shaking a
matchbook three-dimensionally around you
I spent more time yesterday than I'd
like to admit playing this game it's fun
because you get to jump around but
sometimes if you want to your jumps can
have a little extra kick I guess because
of your diet
okay so puzzle farter probably didn't
blow your mind but whoo it feels good to
get off my chest the fact that I love it
one final fact nerf is not just a silly
word it's an acronym that stands for non
expanding recreational foam also I am
made out of Vsauce
I didn't really die but if you have a
secret about yourself leave it in the
comments below and as always thanks for
watching